just to bring you a little bit more on  that breaking news that the queen has  carried out virtual audiences from  windsor castle they are her first  official engagements in seven days since  she was ordered to rest by doctors  cancelling that two-day visit to  northern ireland  and uh then being admitted to hospital  the king edward the seventh hospital for  uh what were described as preliminary  tests she stayed overnight in hospital  before returning to windsor castle where  we're told she's been conducting light  duties ever since here she is being seen  conducting official business albeit via  computer  meeting the ambassador from the republic  of korea gun kim